i don't like your attitude
the defense is wrong
[Music]
thank you
chris sims mike florio pft ot things we
did not get to during today's pft live
also
the audio ends up on the pft pm podcast
feed we'll have an interview that i
taped yesterday with bill's receiver
cole beasley will end the
tuesday wednesday whatever day it is
it's wednesday it feels like tuesday
because chris sims
played hooky on tuesday he's back on
wednesday that that's how i cover for my
blunder i blame it on you uh cole
beasley later in the program to wrap the
pft pm
pftot let's start chris you've been
quiet today let's start with jacoby
bersett he's relieved by the mri results
that came on monday he has a shot at
playing this week for the colts against
the dolphins and they can't let their
guard down against the dolphins because
the cults play down to the level of
whoever they're playing they need jacoby
brissette even though brian hoyer is a
capable backup there's a gap between
hoyer and brissette they need brisette
healthy and out on the field and the
chances of winning the game go down if
per set isn't available yeah definitely
uh you know it's something they'll have
to gauge throughout the week jacoby
bersetz played phenomenal i mean i have
a hard time again thinking that they
lose that game the other day in
pittsburgh if jacoby presets in there i
don't think he makes that mistake of
that pick six down in the end zone that
brian hoyer made uh having said that you
know they're going to have to kind of
gauge it though because it is one of
those things where okay you're you are
better than the miami dolphins you're
right they do kind of play down to their
competition but i would like to think
that they could win a game against the
dolphins regardless uh whether and play
behind that offensive line and run the
ball and have maybe a little bit more of
a game plan like we saw them have
against the kansas city chiefs just to
protect maybe brian where to do to a
degree so
you know hey if he's around 90 or better
then play him but if you feel like it's
in the 75 to 80 range i would set him
out one more week just having the big
picture of the whole season in my mind
you know the other reality is the
dolphins are ripe to be beaten because
they may have guys on that team and
thinking hey we got our win we can coast
for the rest of the month
we're good to go right we don't have to
worry about owen 16. that's one of the
things brian flores the coach of the
team's actually concerned about and he's
already talked to them about it but i
think the dolphins have shown that they
can play well
and even though they only have one win
and the cults have shown they can play
just poorly enough to barely beat bad
teams the eagles have been better than
they've been bad so far this year
although they didn't look so good a few
weeks ago one of the reasons they've
struggled they haven't had desean
jackson who was available week one had
150 plus receiving yards and a pair of
touchdowns in a come-from-behind win
over washington and now jackson on
injured reserve after undergoing core
muscle surgery the problem came up in
week two it or actually coming out of
week one i believe is when it first
emerged but the bottom line is he should
have had surgery a long time ago he
didn't
and now
uh he's not going to be available to the
eagles for the rest of the season chris
and this really keeps the offense from
being as good as it can be it really
does this is a huge blow to this
football team uh it is and you know it's
the first thing like mike what you
talking about it's the first thing i
thought of like
why why did we not just have surgery
from the get-go and you know of course
that's easy for us to say as we sit here
and we don't know all the details and
things like that but man for as long as
he was out uh they could have had
surgery from the get-go and he'd be
coming back healthy right now ready to
go
instead we've wasted the whole year
without desean jackson and i am worried
about them you know their team
you know everyone wants to look at
carson wentz all the time and i want to
go who else there's nobody to be scared
of in that passing game you know i mean
i know zack ertz is good yeah he's great
for a seven yard completion over the
middle of the field he doesn't make any
yards after the catch he doesn't have
like a physical aspect to his game where
he like he breaks tackles or runs down
the middle and people bounce off them
also and jeffrey is a real big target
but not a guy again where defenses are
like finagling their game plan going oh
my gosh if we don't double dow sean
jeffrey we won't survive today uh
there's just nothing to be scared of and
this is i think gonna put more pressure
on that eagles run game to where they're
gonna have to continue to run the ball
to help the passing game out and
hopefully they can do that because they
have the pieces to do it
yeah and look when it comes to surgery i
don't think anybody should want it and
you should only do it if it's a last
chance type of a thing to fix a problem
but it's unfortunate for the eagles that
this wasn't something that desean
jackson did earlier this year he'd be
healthy he'd be back he'd be good to go
and and i'm all for trying to come up
with some other way to fix a problem but
man i tell you what if you want to be on
the field and you know your career is
getting closer to the end far close to
the end in the beginning and you've got
a surgical option that's going to get
you back in six weeks and this
non-surgical thing well maybe it'll work
maybe it'll it won't at some point you
just got you just got to say do it i
understand there's risk you can get
complications and infections and and we
get desensitized to what it means to go
through surgery and to recover from it
but it's unfortunate that it happened
this way for the eagles because uh
desean jackson added something to that
offense and now they don't have it and
chris it's not like they can go out and
find somebody the trade deadline's over
they can't do anything other than sign
antonio brown who probably would be put
on the commission or exempt list right
away what can you really do at this
point if you're the eagles to get a deep
threat into your offense no i that
that's where i get into like you're
right i mean max hollins has a little
speed uh
but you're there is that not that aspect
to take the pressure off oh here's a big
chunk play in the pass game so we don't
always have to go 11 plays 80 yards to
score a touchdown you know the eagles
always have to do that they can never
just go like three plays 80 yards for a
touchdown but i do think the biggest
thing for them going forward is they
have a gigantic physical powerful
offensive line and the year they went to
the super bowl that was the thing they
did best was they ran downhill and just
steamrolled teams and they've done it a
little the last two weeks to give me
hope to go okay they've realized that
but hey kelsey and brooks and you know
sue molo and
of course jason peters or dillard at
left tackle and then lane johnson i mean
come on that's one of the better groups
in all of football i think they got to
continue to ride them and pose their
will hope people start to creep up to
the line of scrimmage and then that can
make al shawn jeffrey and maybe matt
collins or some other receivers a little
bit more of a threat down the field
they've kicked the tires on receiver
jordan matthews who was with the eagles
at one point in the past he's not
exactly going to be the deep threat that
they need you know i i'd be tempted to
call tory smith who's available and
bring him in for a workout and see if he
can run yeah that's a good thought right
because there's just there's nothing
else out there right now and smith at
least knows your system and you could
put him out there and you can have him
try to stretch the field but it's just a
shame that it worked out this way for
the eagles and for dejean jackson that
the the injury couldn't be rehabbed
without surgery and from the eagles
perspective it would have been a lot
better if the surgery would have been
done back in week two or week three all
right the cleveland browns are getting
help in the backfield in the form of
kareem hunt he was the nfl's leading
rusher in 2017 as a rookie with the
chiefs cut by the chiefs last year after
that video emerged in late november of
hunt shoving and kicking a woman outside
of an apartment he was running at a
cleveland hotel the chiefs cut him
because he had told the chiefs he didn't
even leave his apartment well the video
showed he did the league suspended him
eight games now he's free and clear to
return chris
and i don't know what he's going to do
for the browns i mean there's still only
one football nick chubb is a great
running back you put kareem out there
kareem hunt out there and uh
you know i i have to worry about even
fewer opportunities for the guys who may
sound off if they don't get
opportunities and i'm specifically
talking about otto beckham jr yeah well
you're right i mean they're having a
hard enough time getting the ball to
odell beckham jr and jarvis landry let
it go to another guy and involved in the
offense here i think the biggest thing
that he'll do more more than anything
is take a little wear and tear off a
nick chubb you know the the only other
guy they really have that can come in
and carry the ball is what
dontrell hillyard right so kareem hun
clearly more talented than them the
other aspect i think that you might see
is both of the guys on the field at the
same time nick chubb and kareem hunt
where hey kareem hunt you could throw
him out at slot receiver he can do that
type of stuff like an alvin kamara or
that type of running back who can really
run rouse he did that for andy reid and
company in kansas city so not crazy that
way but i think more than anything it's
just going to give them a two-headed
monster especially in the run game
they're they're a good running football
team i mean they've shown throughout the
year that their whole line is capable of
of being pretty good run blockers and i
think that again i'm big of them as
staying staying through the run that's
what made them successful at the end of
last year as well and this could just be
another guy nick chubb more the power
straight ahead guy now you got a guy
like kareem hunt who's a little shiftier
you know maybe he wants to bounce it
outside and do things like that more to
where it gives the defense a different
look and puts a little bit of different
stress on them
chub's averaging just over 100 yards per
game
you mentioned hilliard he's got 49 yards
rushing he's got fewer than baker
mayfield so they have used hillyard
right sparingly and it very well could
be that chubb gets used less down the
stretch but the bottom line is you
introduce a new personality a new skill
set a new weapon into the offense it's
necessarily going to diminish on average
the extent to which we see the others
and that's not good news for odo beckham
jr all right last topic before the cole
beasley interview and this issue came up
earlier in the week with the idea that
chargers could move to london that's bs
that's bogus dean spanos the owner of
the chargers used much more
colorful language and profane language
than that but you know chris it got
peter king and i to talking a little bit
about this yesterday i want to get your
perspective as a guy who played
um
the idea of moving to london living in
london playing in london the road trip
becomes three weeks at a time because
it's not just gonna be you leave on
saturday you come back sunday night it's
gonna be you go to the united states for
multiple games your family is uprooted
there's exchange rate issues there's tax
issues everything is different
culturally what a shock and you're in
your early 20s i i don't think players
are going to want to play in london on a
full-time basis if they move a team
there i don't think so either and hey i
mean i would love to live in london i
mean we know it's one of the great
cities of the world but uh as far as
pulling off the logistics of that that
still does seem extremely difficult to
me you're right the exchange rate there
is an issue there uh and then the other
thing you know you kind of hit it there
at the end you know i just don't know
how comfortable players are gonna feel
you know if they grew up in
west texas or or you know oklahoma or
something like that and they're that far
away from you know hey mom and dad we
got a game this week you want to fly 12
hours to come see us or do that type of
stuff that's just going to be hard to
pull off and you know that's one of the
great joys players have of playing in
the nfl is the fact that hey my family
can come and watch me and do those
things and uh it's just easy for them
that that that complicates things in a
lot of ways you know let alone yeah are
you going to live there the whole off
season do i need to get another house in
the off season here in the states uh how
does that play off because i don't think
a lot of guys are going to want to stay
in london you know all year long through
and through you know for consecutive
years in a row you know people are
raised here born here they're going to
want to be back here at some point so
there's a lot of issues there and i just
i don't see it happening as much as i
like the london games and think the
london fans are ready for an nfl team
i think that ultimately what the london
fans will get is eight games a year that
are a variety pack like the little
cereal boxes where it's going to be
different teams it's not going to be one
home team i don't think it works
logistically and think about the the
ultimate leverage you would have over a
player
on the teams in the united states you
just threatened to trade into london
right i remember adam gates used to
threaten to trade players to cleveland
that was one of the things jarvis landry
said earlier this year threatened to
trade a guy to london talk about
uprooting your life my god and i could
see veteran free agent contracts with a
no trade to london clause in them not
just a blanket no trade clause just you
can't trade me to london the mere fact
that that would even be a consideration
it's just not it's and and again nothing
against london we can't wait to visit
but for football players yeah that's the
last thing they're going to want to do
and peter king made a point yesterday as
we were trying to figure out this whole
chargers report
at at some point if you're going to have
one team it does make sense to have two
you have a natural geographic rival
they've got wembley stadium and the
tottenham stadium where two teams could
play and uh
but again then you'd have two franchises
with 53 guys each in london and all the
coaches and all the support staff it
just
i i just don't think it works the nfl
seems hell-bent on doing it although i
think part of it is chris they'd like to
create the impression they're hell-bent
on doing it because that keeps the
london fans engaged if they think
there's a way that the dominoes fall
that a team gets placed in london yeah i
i think you're probably right there at
the end and i don't know if we need to
keep like dangling that in front of them
i think they're
they're cool i mean i don't know
is london i would like to know maybe
this is something we should put out to
all the people who watch our show when
you say hello to all the people in the
uk and all that you know do they really
want a team or are they content with
just like you said eight ten games a
year and that's cool enough i mean it's
just it's still a soccerous king there
we know that
let me tell you this two things first
there are plenty of fans of nfl
franchises that would prefer to have a
variety pack of games in lieu of the
crap they have to see everything very
true when they go to the stadium like
bengals fans and and the other thing is
this sam farmer the la times pointed
this out he was at the rams bengals game
in london a few weeks ago and
uh when you look at the newspapers in
london and you flip through the sports
pages there's no mention of the nfl
there's still no traction it's a niche
proposition right and there are some
very ardent and intense nfl fans and we
appreciate those folks in the uk and in
ireland but at the same time it has yet
to catch on the way they want it to and
maybe it will take putting a team there
to get the people more serious about it
to make it something that is covered
more than just some oddity you know kind
of like here when you've got manchester
united and one of the other premier
league teams liverpool playing in
charlotte okay liverpool yeah they're
playing in charlotte do we really care
about that it really doesn't resonate
the way that that people would like it
to
uh from london who are tied into the
premier league so that's cool
even if they fill the stadium it doesn't
resonate well you're right and a lot of
times in those games they don't even
play their best players because it's
like it's like a you know a hello wave
to the
you know the american fans type of tour
you know at least the london and i went
to one of those i i saw i saw lionel
messi
sit on his ass for two hours yeah right
yeah so i mean at least the when we
return the favor to them we're putting
our best players on the field and doing
all that but uh the soccer's a long
season that's another discussion all
together but yeah i just don't know if
it's feasible mike i don't see how you
could do it not fair competitively two
to ask a team to go like have a west
coast trip and be away from home for
three four weeks in a row or whatever it
may be
that that is going to be too tough and
not fair for them you know as far as
just wins and losses as the season goes
along
yeah i mean think of how strange that
will be the talk has always been there
would be an east coast base of
operations for the london team
where they would they would act that
that would be a separate headquarters
where you'd be for three weeks at a time
your road trips would be
three four games and then you go back to
london for three or four games it just
it doesn't make sense there's so many
issues so many logistical problems i
don't like it i understand why they talk
about it but i don't think it ever
happens the london redcoats versus the
new england patriots would be a great
matchup though i would really like that
that would be cool yeah that that would
be that would be a revenge game right
right uh yeah all right um
i can't think of a good transition so
let me just say this cole beasley bill's
receiver joined me by phone yesterday
we're going to play that for you now and
then chris and i will say goodbye on the
back end of the interview here's a brief
conversation from tuesday with bill's
receiver cole beasley
all right joining us now a guy who is in
his first season with the buffalo bills
he's receiver cole beasley and i'm going
to mention the plug right out of the
gates cole because it's rare that i do
one of these that i actually own one of
the things that we're plugging the
polaris ranger there is one right below
me where i'm sitting parked in my garage
tell me what you got going on with
polaris
i actually own on three of them so i'm
right there
um but i just i teamed up with with
polaris ranger to celebrate the best
stories in texas high school football um
texas native and i know a little bit
about it so
i really wanted to get involved with
that and we've also partnered with dave
campbell's texas football to identify
five schools that are playing for more
than wins and losses
their stories have been captured in
short videos as part of polaris most
driven team campaign and anyone can go
watch these on texasfootball.com
and they can vote for who they think is
the most driven team so it's pretty cool
they'll have an opportunity to
actually win their own vehicle
and maybe give them a little bit more
vote of motivation
and i i noticed you're a texas guy born
and raised high school college cowboys
yeah you're gonna have to put like a
snow plo a snow plow and and snowmobile
tracks on your polaris pretty soon in
buffalo do you know what you're getting
yourself into when you moved to western
new york
why i didn't bring him i didn't bring
the polaris rangers to buffalo i left
them in texas with my dad at my hunting
ranch um they get better use there
so they're not here but
um
i didn't even really really think about
the weather that much it didn't really
matter to me i've played in cold games
before i've played in one that was
like negative 13 i believe in chicago
one year so
i've actually had some of my best games
in the cold so
i really didn't worry about it too much
that wasn't really a factor
you've hit the bills at a great time the
team is six and two you've been on some
good teams in the past in dallas what's
your assessment the biggest reason why
the bills are six and two
um i think they got a lot of a lot of
talent for one
um and then we have a lot of young
players that are hungry
and want to win man and want to be the
best and and when you're surrounded by a
bunch of guys who all want to be the
best that's that's usually what happens
so
this is fun going to work with these
guys and
it's been a blast so far and um you know
we really have a bond on this team
that's
um not like anything i've ever been a
part of maybe maybe high school football
was the last time in texas when it was
like this i mean there's so many things
that can get in the way at this level
with all the moving parts but
somehow here you know mcdermott has done
a great job of creating a real family
environment and
we're always together there's always
something going on there's always
something to do so it's a really cool
deal
you got one of the best fan bases in all
of sports the bill's mafia give me your
best story so far of something you've
seen or heard from one of those bills
fans
uh probably the best story i have is
when i arrived um there were fans there
with with a bunch of wings um waiting on
me and
um you know people actually they asked
me if i actually ate them i was like of
course i did and they brought me
to the airport and when i arrived so
naturally i'm going to eat them you know
that's what they're for so i want to let
them go to waste but
then also
this past sunday when i when i jumped in
the stands on the touchdown i got i
probably smelled so much like
like beer the entire game it was awesome
you know i had a blast partying with him
after my touchdown
that's a risky move i always admire a
guy that does that you never know what's
going to get grabbed once you jump into
the stands do you have any hesitation
about doing that
man when you're in the moment dude you
don't even care you don't even think
about it um and i spiked the ball and
then i saw the the fans waving me over
they were having a good time i wanted to
have a good time with them
your adrenaline's like through the roof
when you score a touchdown um
i can't even explain
any other feeling that's that's similar
to that so
i had no hesitation at all i was ready
to get rowdy with him for a little bit
you've made a great connection with josh
allen you didn't have the benefit of the
offseason program you had surgery you
were recovering from how have you been
able to click with him so quickly
um really it's just constant
communication even when we're not on the
field we're talking about it so
you know we'll analyze the film and
i have a lot of freedom in a lot of my
routes so communication is important
like what are you thinking here what do
you see there and i just want to make
sure that
what i do is on the same page with what
he what he's thinking at that time so
we just have to see the same thing and a
lot of that goes
off the practice field in the meeting
rooms as well
he's still new and he's still raw and
you've had the benefit of playing with
some guys like tony romo and dak
prescott how much have you been trying
to help him understand how other
quarterbacks have done things in an
effort to bring him along and help his
development as the starter
um
you know really you don't you don't talk
about other guys because every
quarterback is unique in their own way
um
you know really all i can do is is
just be in the spot that i'm supposed to
be in at all times and be as quarterback
friendly as possible um and not
not get too crazy with the freedom that
they've given me um and just be exactly
where he expects me to be
at all times because i mean if there's
there's a time that i'm not then it's
then we start second guessing down the
road so
i just got to be as consistent as
possible for him and and play my best
ball and get open
we all knew that the cowboys would host
the bills this year we knew that from
the end of last season when the schedule
is locked in but when you saw
buffalo at dallas thanksgiving what was
your first thought
my first thought was i actually thought
i was going to get a thanksgiving
but
i'm not so that was really what i
thought about it had nothing to do with
the game
i was kind of excited to to not play on
thanksgiving for once since we did it
every year in dallas but
looks like i'm going to be playing on
thanksgiving again so those are really
my thoughts had nothing to do with with
actually playing the cowboys
i mean short week football short week
football and every team plays one of
those games almost every team plays one
of those games every year is there
something that you've learned about
playing on thanksgiving that you're
gonna impart to your teammates so
they'll be ready to go when the time
comes to play that game
not really i mean
i mean i don't know though i i've played
on thanksgiving every season so it's
like a normal normal thing i guess um
but really it's just like a normal game
for me um
that's that's what i'll tell them if if
they ask but i'm pretty sure they'll
approach it the same way it doesn't
matter if it's on thanksgiving christmas
or
you know any other day you know it's
it's still a game we're going there to
win
it makes it no different you know the
team we play or whatever you know you
just approach it the same way and that's
that's really how you have to do it
how conscious are you of the reality
that from the outside looking in the
cowboys are a team that's basically at
the center of the nfl's universe and
it's the other 31 franchises trying to
jockey for position from your
perspective do you sense that do you
feel that now that you're not with the
cowboys
um
i don't no not really um i mean i know
that they are yes but
um
i don't it was never really something
that i that i really cared about being a
part of like being the center of the
universe or anything like that um
i've never been a big like um i don't
know i don't even know what you call
that but
i don't really care much about being in
the public like that you know i just i
enjoy my teammates i enjoy playing
football and i enjoy being with my
family and that's that's pretty much it
um so
as far as all the other stuff the the
popularity and the publicity i i mean i
could do without that i came here to
play football and
and come here for all that so all right
hey great talking to you pal and uh all
the best in the future
all right thank you
all right that's it for pft ot on this
wednesday chris thanks as always for
hanging around thursday no pftot because
it's the joint pfd pm chris sims
unbuttoned mega pix podcast i've caught
you in the best bets and you know i've
caught you in the best bets and this
week i'm pulling ahead chris i mean i i
had a bad week of pixal together i mean
straight up i don't even want to look at
my record i know it wasn't good i doubt
yours was real good either but i know my
my week last week was an absolute
disaster so uh i'm not looking forward
to starting that show off and having to
read the records and all that but don't
worry a lot of time left this is when i
really focus in and hone in this is
playoff football time the best people
start to rise to the top once it comes
november i'm gonna whup your ass florio
these last eight weeks you like that all
right well tomorrow no i don't tomorrow
we'll get the official results from week
nine and get you ready for week ten we
have pft live before that though
tomorrow morning 6 a.m eastern on radio
7 a.m eastern on nbcsn chris you're
doing a
christian's unbuttoned today right it's
the what the bleep happened show yes it
is it's yeah well can i say that word
but yes what the hell
what the f happened yes we're gonna go
do that on our podcast today all right
we'll check that out later today we'll
do pfc live in the joint mega podcast
tomorrow everybody have a great
wednesday we'll see you thursday peace
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports